I have a question do you do you think
and this is kind of cool for you do you
think that poor people are less valuable
than rich people because when you a lot
of people don't know this but that's a
common argument that people you use for
eugenics it's not about so so basically
so basically that that poor people
should be eradicated and in some of like
the founders plan Planned Parenthood
which is more of a uh it's more of a U.S
organization like that was what they
were fighting for was Eugenics
um which is like basically poor people
should die same with like minorities no
no it's not poverty it's about trauma
it's about trauma it's about passing on
unhealed Souls they're going to then go
because her people do you think do you
think that we're spoiled because even
like people that are in like the lowest
income bracket now they're still richer
than most people were in all of human
history so then like because by that
logic then everyone pretty much should
have died all the time no this is the
thing like I'll tell you something I
grew up privileged then my dad passed
away in my life turned around and I came
to England and all of a sudden I went
from being a after being down here and
being the poor kid but none of that
situation changed my happiness because
my mom is a loving woman who did
everything to make sure that we were
happy we're okay we didn't have all the
money and yet all her support and love
got me to be a woman that I am today I'm
grateful for that on the flip side I
have friends that went through similar
things all completely different
situations where their parents were not
equipped to give them the love and the
support that they needed to be wholesome
human beings wholesome adults that can
actually lead a life responsibly and not
have to have those traumas that are
getting them to get themselves in
trouble so that's why people go that's
why a lot of black people go to prison
okay so next question do you where
where's the cut off then like where
should abortion be legal what about what
about nine months no I feel like that's
just okay okay so so what what point
he's like I could say probably to the
point where the brain starts to develop
because once the brain starts to develop
properly then that's when you it that's
when the life like the more
Consciousness starts to go and when
you're actually picking up a lot of the
the signals from the outside where your
the fetus turns into actually something
that's aware yeah aware yeah that's it
brain waves are what about six weeks so
you would say six weeks well that's
still not developed enough that's just
brain no you said the brain this is the
thing once your brain there's different
stages to it so when when the brain is
development developing there's brain
waves and then there's other things that
you receive certain information it
depends on the level of information that
that brain can now process okay so what
level of information well I would say
probably the cut off point of three to
four months is actually quite good and I
know they go up to six months yeah it's
six months in the UK and after six
months if there is any even a minor
disability such as a cleft palate
um or something you know something that
minor There's No Limit that's the
current rule in Canada There's No Limit
period many states in the US There's No
Limit can I just add like with the
question you asked me across like at the
end of the day my mindset to it it's not
about poor people being less valuable
like that's not even what we're talking
about what I'm talking about what I'm
just saying is at the end of the day if
you know you're living and this is a
very common thing yeah a lot of times
people who are living in struggle and
poverty who can't even look after
themselves they just [ __ ] him yeah like
they have nothing else going on
hold on let me just say this bro like
yeah and then they just bring uh they
just having kids bro like you could yeah
just go outside you're gonna see people
pushing prams and like they're nothing
going on and their kids bro a lot of
these kids what what happens to them
join gangs uh crime they go prison end
up in the ground whatever bro like so
like all of these other fairy tales oh
yeah maybe they're gonna end up yeah it
happens but bro it's rare real and truly
majority of them are gonna end up [ __ ]
up those actually aren't the women
getting abortions only eight percent of
women below the poverty line are getting
abortions for one out of three women
that make over forty seven thousand
dollars per year actually
your question was about the people that
was in poverty yeah but I'm saying like
like there's a like I'm saying when you
argue that like you're basically like
you might not mean it like that but when
you're arguing that those people should
get abortions you're basically saying
that poor people should never write each
other
for example yeah you are like let's say
25 you go to the club and you meet this
[ __ ] but he's hot and he decides to
have a one-night stand I know you decide
to open your legs that should fall blah
blah you get pregnant now cool you are
having your own issues in life you are
uh definitely not equipped to be a
mother you're not even responsible
whatever and the guy on top of that he's
not a partner that is going to be able
to even support your child in many ways
there you go it's your decision if you
want to dominate the determinated
money it's about mental it's about how
how prepared are you as a person and if
you're afraid and you don't want to do
it okay but just be ready to deal with
the consequences
actually like you know contraception yes
yeah
there's so much contraception so when
you're in that stage where you're having
the pregnancy what have you done to
prevent that I understand Auntie's
situation was very you know it happened
I'm an exception to every Rule and I
accept that yeah there is contraception
like involved to stop these things from
happening and we've completely ignored
that and went on to the fact that we've
been Reckless and we're pregnant so what
what concepts
I very much no I've got no kids
really for a guy all you can do is wear
condoms so really who really is in
charge
who's got more Authority in that yeah
because my in my opinion I think women
really need to do a better job of like
um making sure that they don't fall into
that trap because the majority of the
contraception is down to their minute
like you know what I'm saying and then
even let's say even if you have a
girlfriend and you get her pregnant and
she doesn't want to have the kids she
ain't having it bro thanks yeah so
foreign
do you think that um Plan B is an
abortion because I always get this
question and I don't know enough about
it it would depend on exactly how it
works
um I don't know next day the the next
day
I know what it is I'm talking about the
actual mechanism by which it works does
it prevent the fertilization I I
actually don't understand it
if it prevents fertilization it does
okay if it passes fertilization then no
that's not enough I don't think I think
they all stop the embryo from attacking
that's what you said prevents it from
from the beginning but it's already
fertilized right when the sperm touches
the egg that's already like has
conception already is it is it a
contraceptive
I've tried to actually find the answer
to this yeah and it seems to be a little
bit up in the air that so he's only all
right as long as the egg the the touch
of thing is like
I care about being elect intellectually
honest and consistent right so human
life begins at conception right left
uninterrupted from that point this is
why it's dumb when people make that
point oh well masturbating is the same
as like no because a sperm on its own
doesn't do anything it never develops
into a human an egg on its own does not
but once they meet if we were to rewind
any of our lives and go back to where
our life began it would be from that
moment of conception that's when the DNA
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible